[Music]
welcome to bananamores i'm so excited to
watch this next performer light up
the bananamore stage get ready for
comedy greatness
thank you so much mitzi uh it's such a
pleasure to be here
if you guys don't know me i'm chanel ali
you might recognize me from mtv's girl
code i was in the last season of that
show which was also
the last season of that show so you're
welcome the pleasure is all mine
i feel comfortable with you guys i want
to just be honest and let you know that
i'm a biracial person i'm biracial which
is funny to me
every time i say it because i feel
pretty black
i feel very black every day when i wake
up
and go outside but growing up i didn't
know i was biracial
had no idea i was biracial talks in
junior high a girl ran up to me at
school very out of breath like chanel
i saw you last night at target with this
old white lady
and she was buying you a bra what is
going
on and i was like whoa chelsea
that don't even sound like me you know i
was worried about my reputation then i
thought about it
and i was like i was at target last
night but i was there
with my grandmother and she is not oh
so then i went home and i walked up to
my grandmother that day
bold as brass i pointed in her face and
i said hey
are you white and she said
yes what did you think i was and i said
i never thought about it before
i knew that i was black because of b-e-t
so i just assumed by association my
grandmother was probably black too like
i know she wasn't very dark-skinned and
she didn't really
handle beach days as well as others but
we all got our stuff
who was i to judge she said no i'm 100
italian which means you are part of town
she told me that her parents
moved to this country from italy she
pulled out a picture frame
showed me two very nice looking white
people i said oh my gosh my whole life
i thought that was a brand new frame
and you just been waiting to feel it
everything is alive
like yeah i thought my grandmother was
lazy i didn't know she was white
now i'm 32 i'm 32. i know my ethnicity
but i'm still learning a lot about
myself it wasn't till this year that i
was able to admit that i'm the jealous
type
i'm one of those women but not in the
traditional sense more so in the sense
where i don't like it when my friends
tell me about their
other funny friends
i do not want to hear about that it
could be something small said to the
side like yeah i was at work the other
day
talking to jenny you know chanel she's
so funny you would love her i'm like
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
what do you mean by that what are you
what are you trying to say you you like
jenny's jokes
does jenny make you laugh
it's cool it's cool i just you know i
remember a time when
i could make your life just fine i
remember one time i made you laugh so
hard
you cried a little and then you peed a
little
i didn't tell nobody i'm a good friend
does uh jenny make you pee
[Music]
no i don't think she does no no no if
jenny's so
funny just tell me where
jenny lives
let's go to the house right now see if
she makes me laugh why do you keep
trying to leave i already locked the
door come sit down
and tell me about your funny friend
you know what's that that's the most
honest joke
you guys have been kind i am chanel
ali thank you so much please keep it
going for mitzi
that was bananas i want more thanks for
coming to bananas
more